[Musica]
[Applauso]
quali furono le origini di roma una
delle più grandi città del mondo antico
delle più grandi potenze del mondo
antico son origine molto interessante
perché all'inizio diciamo della storia
c'è un profugo un fuggiasco uno che ha
perso tutto durante una guerra e ne è
uscito dalla peggiore guerra che mai si
sia registrata nella cultura antica la
guerra di [ __ ] con pochi i fuggiaschi
salito su delle navi è scampato
miracolosamente a un naufragio e questo
già ci ricorda delle cose molto
contemporanee tanto più che questo anno
fra cio avviene proprio nel canale di
sicilia dove oggi naufragano purtroppo i
nostri emigranti finalmente riesce a
raggiungere l'italia qui dopo lotte
travagliate conflitti di divinità
eccetera si stabilisce un nuovo popolo
che è un misto di troiani e di latini da
questo un popolo misto dopo varie tappe
si giungerà la fondazione un'altra città
albalonga e poi finalmente un fondatore
romolo fonderà la città di roma
romolo quindi è un discendente di
profughi e di popoli misti il quale per
fondare la nuova città che chiamerà a
roma nel suo nome si comporta in questo
modo fa venire da tutte le parti
d'italia
tutti luoghi circonvicini uomini di ogni
provenienza potevano essere schiavi
liberi perseguitati della giustizia un
po di tutto e li raccoglie che in una
località proprio in un luogo fisico che
chiama asylum cioè luogo di intoccabili
luoghi dove non c'è persecuzione
quindi questo gruppo di uomini misto
insieme all'uomo lo dà inizio alla
fondazione della città e qui viene
l'aspetto più interessante più
appassionante perché per fondare la
città si procede innanzitutto a scavare
una fossa una forza circolare che sarà
il centro della futura città questa
possa porta un nome
mundus è il mondo quindi è come se
questi romani stessero in qualche modo
ricreando il mondo creando il loro mondo
in questa forza vengono gettati come
dice plutarco nella sua biografia di
romulo tutto ciò che è buono secondo la
natura e tutto ciò che è buono secondo i
costumi quindi diciamo alimenti e
oggetti culturali non si dà inizio a una
nuova civiltà ma soprattutto in questa
fossa in questa possa vengono gettate
delle zolle di terra perché perché
ciascuno di questi uomini provenienti da
lontano ha portato con sé una zolla
della propria terra e adesso la getta in
questa fosse di fondazione perché le
zolle vengano rimescolate farà loro
vengono mescolati con la terra che le
ospita in altre parole i romani si
stanno creando facendo la terra della
loro città e la stanno facendo
mescolando terre di provenienze diverse
quindi all'inizio di roma c'è un gruppo
di uomini misti di uno stesso ceppo ma
di ceppi diversissimi che fonda una
città che si basa su una terra mista
come sono loro l'inizio di roma e quindi
marchiato indelebilmente dalla
mescolanza una mescolanza che già c'era
prima perché il fondatore più lontano
enea era comunque proveniente dalla
città remota [ __ ] era un fuggiasco
perseguitato il cui popolo si era fuso
con un altro popolo e poi
progressivamente si era creata una nuova
fusione al momento di fondare la città
una fusione più visibile più più
sensibile perché era una fusione di
uomini e una fusione di terra e questa
sarà poi la cifra che caratterizzerà
tutta la cultura romana
ma perché in questo mito di fondazione è
un mito di fondazione non è mai una
storia in una fondazione ma il modo in
cui un popolo rappresenta se stesso
vuole presentarsi agli altri popoli
in questo mito di fondazione è iscritta
profondamente la cifra della mescolanza
e tito livio ad inizio delle sue storie
dirà proprio questo cioè che la forza la
forza di roma stava appunto nella
mescolanza se noi ora facciamo un
parallelo con quanto avviene nella
grecia classica fra quinto e quarto
secolo
vediamo sorgere esattamente l'opposto o
meglio sorgere un mito che dice
esattamente l'opposto di ciò che dice il
mito di fondazione di roma si in quegli
anni infatti si generalizza un racconto
che è fondato sulla cosiddetta autoctoni
a cioè letteralmente l'essere di quella
terra venire da quella terra
in altre parole gli ateniesi si
raccontano questa storia
secondo cui loro sarebbero nati
direttamente dalla terra che l'iraq e
adesso li ospita
sarebbero figli di quella terra e per
dimostrarlo ulteriormente diranno che
hanno avuto due re ceco presidi three
tonio che furono insieme dei re serpenti
perché erano per metà serpenti il
serpente l'animale della terra
nell'animale ctonio per eccellenza
quindi la rappresentazione greca segna s
soprattutto va anche le altre città è
rovesciata rispetto a quella di roma
qui è la terra che crea negli uomini e
che crea uomini che vengono tutti da una
stessa stirpe di quella terra ii a roma
sono gli uomini che creano la terra e
sono tutti uomini nisti mescolati due
modi opposti di vedere la fondazione
della città questi modi opposti di
vedere la fondazione delle città si
ripercuotano poi in quelle che sono come
dire le politiche
diritto che in regola che governa questa
città perché roma città che nasce sotto
il segno dell'apertura e anche la città
che concede con facilità la cittadinanza
ai popoli vicini e poi non a quelli più
lontani fina che con l'edito di
caracalla poi la cittadinanza verrà
concessa a tutti gli abitanti
dell'impero addirittura un privato a
roma può liberare uno schiavo e farne un
cittadino ne farà un libertus che dopo
qualche generazione avrà dei discenti
che sono cittadini a pieno titolo
quindi si diventa romani questa la cosa
importante si diventa romani se si e
stranieri si diventa romani persino se
si è schiavi ci sia questa possibilità è
molto in sintonia con questo modo
originario l'immissione di libertà di
senso di libertà di indipendenza dalla
provenienza fisica o etnica
se noi ci spostiamo ad atene invece una
città dell'auto nia la città degli
abitanti di son venuti su dalla terra si
scopre che i cittadini ateniesi non è
possibile diventarlo lo si è
bisogna essere figli di una coppia di
ateniesi gli altri gli stranieri non
parliamo degli schiavi
non hanno alcuna speranza di diventare
cittadini
atene è una città della chiusura roma è
una città dell'apertura infatti in una
celebre murazione l'imperatore claudio
affronterà questi temi
l'occasione è data dalla volta in cui
volle far diventare senatori dei galli
membri di famiglie
galli che trovò l'opposizione che è
molto contemporanea
qualcuno gli disse un senatore italico è
molto meglio non sia nato regali insomma
una
opposizione localistica e lui rispose ma
noi abbiamo avuto come il re un uomo
tarquinio che a casa sua era disprezzato
perché era figlio di una tarquinese e di
un greco e noi l'abbiamo fatto diventare
il nostro sovrano cioè che paura possono
farci dei senatori che vengono da un
altro popolo da un'altra etnia e galli e
poi ancora continuava l'imperatore
claudio il nostro re fu così saggio che
al mattino considerò un popolo un popolo
di nemici a sera questo popolo era già
diventato un popolo di cittadini quindi
aveva la capacità romolo di integrare
gli altri e anzi continua l'imperatore
claudio che cos'è che ha rovinato i
grandi imperi della grecia cioè le
grande potere disparte il grande potere
di atene il non saper trattare con
l'incapacità di includere dentro di loro
i propri nemici gli altri
questa che è la grande grande lascito
che roma ci ha lasciato
ed è uno degli insegnamenti più preziosi
che ci ha lasciato questa cultura e che
noi oggi potremmo e dovremmo seguire
perché proviamo a immaginare l'europa di
oggi tutti questi giovani questi ragazzi
che abbandonano i loro paesi
in italia purtroppo spesso semplicemente
perché l'italia non ha niente da offrire
ma anche per altri motivi perché trovano
punto opportunità migliori all'estero
perché hanno voglia di vivere all'estero
immaginiamo sento di questi italiani che
si spostano in francia in germania in
svezia
anche in inghilterra adesso non sarà più
così dopo la black si saranno più
difficili le cose ma pensiamo a tutti
questi portoghesi che si trovano in
in danimarca ai tedeschi che sono andati
in inghilterra i polacchi che sono
spostati altrove eccetera immaginiamo se
tutti questi giovani si fossero portati
dietro una zolla di terra l'avessero
gettata nella terra da cui sono stati
accolti
ecco questo è il senso è quello che si
sta creando secondo me in europa oggi
che si stanno rimescolando le nazioni
sul modello romano cioè si sta creando
un identità maggiore che non è
un'identità puramente italiana tedesca e
olandese portoghese no ma l'identità
europea che come sapevano i romani
conserva anche l'identità e la
appartenenza originaria cioè gettare
quella quella zolla di terra non
significava rinunciare al rapporto con
la propria terra anzi significava
rinforzarlo aggiungere qualche cosa non
portare via io non ho mai creduto a
queste viti etnici delle radici
dell'identità della cultura perché i
romani la cultura in senso tradizionale
ma in senso che ti imprigiona perché
romani ci hanno insegnato che la forza
invece una cultura come una forza di un
popolo e la sua capacità di integrare la
sua capacità di accogliere ed è quello
che sta avvenendo in europa con questa
circolazione di persone e quello che sta
avvenendo nel mondo quando a dispetto
delle barriere dei confini che si
vogliono erigere un po dovunque
in realtà le nostre comunità nazionali
stanno accogliendo stranieri provenienti
da altri luoghi anche loro con la loro
zona di terra anche loro pronti fa
trapiantarsi anche loro pronti a
continuare questo straordinario
movimento culturale che io ho
esemplificato attraverso l'esempio di
roma antica ma che poi la cifra in
generale
di qualsiasi cultura di qualsiasi evento
storico la mescolanza raggiungere
l'inventare attraverso l'ingresso del
nuovo dentro il vecchio
[Applauso]